how else has life changed for you
because let's face it this fund you did
back then which I think was a eight
million dollar fund or something or
maybe was a ten million dollar fund but
you only call down seven or eight
million of it I know a lot of insight
information about it from not you
essentially but from a lot of the LPS
well that makes me feel good yeah I
don't think you get you're not out there
like telling people these details but
just so people are clear the audience
since they know we're friendly a lot of
your LPS talk to me obviously and a lot
of people are pretty excited about
having been an LP and this fund I don't
know what the name of that fund was but
I know that it was somewhere between a
six and eight million dollar fund and
now the returns on that fund are in the
billions like two billion or something
is that generally brush that's play yeah
sure this is this make it the greatest
fund ever in the history of Silicon
Valley or is like Costa had one I
believe that had some crazy return to
and obviously the Google fund for
Sequoia do you know because they do keep
track of these things in databases where
that fund system the history of Silicon
Valley you should ask the people who
take care of you know keep track of
those databases but right but you're an
amount of budget is the reason you hear
about it from your friends yeah there's
so many of them were my friends because
when you go out to raise your first fun
the big banks and stuff they want to
write you checks it's your friends who
actually make it happen and so this you
know what I do would have been possible
without real relationships with great
people people I'd worked with people I
gotten to know who were willing to put
you know in some cases material amounts
of money for them to work here and it
makes me super happy that that has
played out well for them I mean our
funds have had Twitter and Instagram and
stuff like that at you know in Heroku
stuff that's paid the bills like that
and obviously stuff like uber that I
think is still on its way it could be a
thousand X fund it's 500 X now is that
right I mean that's again you're just
clutching at straws right now I'm
triangulating here this is like a Karis
wisher style it's not he doesn't suit
you though yeah the presumptive question
so when you do something like that is
there a follow up problem I mean I'm
just here's the others I thought there's
a follow problem I'll tell you what yeah
I mean our second fund is somewhere
around like an 11 or 12 acts and people
are a little let down by that yeah only
return 10 times everybody when the
market would have returned I [ __ ] you
not
and I don't
that is like a humble brag about that
return I literally say it as like a
true-to-life problem people give a [ __ ]
because it's only tracking do you know
yeah over sex it is say and like in our
third fund is I think it's already like
one and a half it's like a year old and
I think it's one and a half or so and
people are kind of asking what's going
on it really happens the expectations
are kind of ridiculous when you look at
this business that we're in this angel
investing early stage investing could
your early stage still yeah you remain
early stage yeah it it is a little
mind-blowing because you can work
exceptionally hard on ten funds and one
defines your career and these funds take
seven years to play out yeah but at the
same time it's kind of it's it's a rape
game I mean if I if I have a couple
funds lose and we've never had a fun
come even close to losing but if I have
a couple funds lose nobody really blames
me yeah the only focus on the ones that
I hit out of the park right right I mean
some of those guys you've mentioned
earlier have lost a lot of money yeah
four people and no one brings it up
right it's just it's it's pretty easy to
be a VC in terms of reputational
management as long as you're not a fraud
and as long as you're not you don't
build a reputation for doing bad things
to people yeah money side like it's a
cult of personality and it's not that
hard to manage for most of these people
if you look at the industry as a whole
it it generally loses money right and
the amount of money it loses is
equivalent to the fees that the VCS take
out of it like if you just look at the
macro level there are these funds that
perpetually do well as a you know if you
were to invest in all the sequoia funds
or all the Excel funds or all the KP
funds you do well but along the way they
definitely have vehicles that are under
water and people don't hold against them
you know and take it personally and so